en vert pendant ce temps championnat des
champions européens vous avez pure en
suivre une partie hier en direct dans
les jeux du stade
mcenroe contre borg mcenroe en finale
donc après avoir battu borg en trois
sets a été battu aujourd'hui par lendl 3
6 7 6 6 3 6 3 c'est à mi-chemin ce
tournoi entre le tournoi exhibition et
le tournoi officiel
mais gérard holtz vous vous êtes attaché
particulièrement ou pas de björn borg
pour savoir si oui ou non ce grand
bonhomme était de retour oui c'est vrai
revers chapatte c'était vous l'avez dit
un tournoi non-officiel est un tournoi
sur invitation avec une bourse tout à
fait exceptionnel pensez un peu lendl
aujourd'hui à gagner 140 millions de
centimes donc bourse exceptionnel
plateau exceptionnel mcenroe lendl
wilander et l'extraterrestre city
puisque nastase l'appeler ainsi björn
borg unborn revenu c'était sa grande
rentrée européenne alors j'ai la chance
mais qui m'accorde une dizaine de
minutes d'entretien il n'existe à vos
charmes même pas borg
il m'a expliqué qu'ils n'avaient pas
encore pris de décision pour roland
garros mais que ces histoires de
qualification d'année dernière il est
trouvé stupide qui n'avait pas non plus
pris de décision pour la coupe davis
avec la suède l'année prochaine tout en
me disant que s'il faisait équipe avec
wilander il serait un batave
pratiquement et puis il jouera l'année
prochaine il a décidé au moins douze
tournois officiels en commençant au mois
de janvier sans doute à bruxelles et
c'était donc la grande rentrée de
l'extraterrestre john borg